oh sometimes when you wake up in the
morning you wake up to some glorious
this actually isn't the first time i've
seen a trailer of sorts to the dune
movie when i was watching tennis it was
one of the greatest
things ever i'm sitting there in the
theater and it was a trailer for the
trailer but it was still a solid minute
or so of footage it seemed like a minute
maybe it was 30 seconds i'm pretty sure
it was a minute but i was sitting in the
movie theater i was there and i just
heard the words and then i had a
reaction it was pretty much like
remove your hand from the box and you
die
oh it's in the box yeah that's how it
went down this i haven't been this
excited for a movie trailer or a movie
in a very long time
i love dune i know the 80s movie is
flawed but i still love it it's pretty
fundamentally impossible for me to
separate the objective filmmaking
element
and my enjoyment don't know what to say
i watched it all the time yeah at a
point in my adult life i was like it is
flawed
still like it but admittedly even though
that is the case i have felt for a while
that
the story of dune has a lot to offer the
big screen so when i heard denny
villeneuve was the one to do it that was
perfect because blade runner 2049
even if you didn't like the movie there
is a fundamental thing to take away from
the movie's execution and that
is he gives you a gorgeous movie that
does
pay respects to the source material and
i heard this movie coincides more with
the book i haven't read the book i have
the book i have this
edition of the book i've had it for a
while i haven't read it i would like to
read it before the movie comes out but
fire emblem path of writing says i'm
gonna beat itself that sounded worse
than i
intended in fact you know what now that
i have the book let's do a thumbnail you
ready here we go happy face
there we go that's good that's excited
face thumbnail holding a book like a
douche all that is to say i like what i
have seen
in this trailer thus far i mean i will
say
this trailer has a more concise plot
than the old movie dead in this trailer
paula tradies is told like yeah your
ancestors weren't good leaders he was
like well my dad's a good leader he has
a planet she's like he's gonna lose that
well he's gonna go to
dune he's gonna have that now he's gonna
lose that too you have to step up and be
more deep and so here we are on the
quest of paula tradies which
paul the tradies in this trailer would
again you know i haven't read the book
now because i just said in this video
but maybe the book's like so
he was a boyish man who looked 14 or so
in the old movie he's like hi
i am palmut he looks like he's ready to
save the universe or at the very least a
galaxy or two but this paula tradies is
like i don't know i'm unsure of myself i
have questions
and i need answers and so i can get
behind that though he looks like he's on
the quest you know he's like i will
start out
paula tradie's the boy i shall become
paula traitors the man i shall become
you see a couple of brief images of
stella skarsgard as the baron heart
conan which when i heard he was cast i
was like great casting
he's gonna need a fat suit for sure
which it looks like he has but again we
only see a couple of brief glimpses the
side of his face him coming out of his
oil bath and that's it but even in those
couple glimpses
he looks like he's gonna be menacing
i'll kill him
i've always felt he was great casting oh
the cast in this movie is
solid jason mamoa yes i uh i stole his
beard but before he looked like he was
all like permission to come aboard
now he's like permission to come aboard
sir i have no beard it's weird to see
him without a beard
oscar isaac is a leader of tradies
rebecca ferguson is lady jessica because
rebecca ferguson is simply perfection i
would marry her i mean i'm never getting
married
but if i was to be married if i was to
get married it would be to rebecca
ferguson regardless i'm a huge fan she's
amazing and i think she's gonna be great
as lady jessica batista i've we've seen
batista the humorous batista the tragic
and now we're going to see batista the
vicious zendaya anytime an actor has
something that can
break them away from that mcu-ified
typecast i enjoy that for them i like
that i like that they have that
opportunity
and i'm interested to see what they can
bring to it this could be a big moment
for zendaya and i'm happy that she has
it you do see
things that are familiar to the old
movie for me
in this movie in this trailer for the
movie anyway like that scene in the old
dune when the sand worm eats the
technodrome patrick stewart's like my
god with a monster
oh [ __ ] you logan what a monster the
sand worms
look enormous i will say i missed the
three
mouth dynamic of this this looks like
just a big hole no
it does not look like an ass that is an
eyeball it looks like an iris
that's a sand [ __ ] that's a sand
eyeball know the difference it's
important regardless game of thrones in
space my friends that's what dunes
should be
and that's what it looks like denny
villeneuve could bring us here or at
least the first four
seasons of game of thrones you know when
it was great before the show runners had
to go off on their own didn't have
george rr martin's work so they
kind of were about as organized as a
monkey trying to [ __ ] a football
that game of thrones so yeah the dune
trailer looks great i even like the font
is that weird because it's it's kind of
it's the same
letter or symbol it's just do you and
it's just all
90 degree turns of the same shape i
don't know it's just
i was like that's pretty slick modern
and that never crossed my mind to be
possible
most important thing is wait a minute
that's not helen mirren
oh i thought it was all right so the
dune trailer have you seen it what did
you think about it did you see the
trailer on tenet
have you been excited for it for a while
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you